hi I'm Patti Kim whether you're getting
ready to take on the morning or just
soaking in the shower at the end of a
long day the bathroom could be a retreat
from the world but it's also where over
sixty percent of the water used indoors
gets consumed like to save water and
money the bathrooms a great place to
start let's take a look and the biggest
consumer of water in the bathroom tada
the toilet
toilets made before 1993 use up to 8
gallons of water per flush compared to
only 1.6 gallons used by modern fixtures
it's a good idea to replace pre 1993
toilets if you can now if you're not
sure exactly how old your toilet is well
all you have to do is take the lid off
the tank and check out the underside
because usually there's a manufacturing
date stamped underneath even if you
can't replace your toilet right away you
can still save water using a 1 liter
plastic bottle just fill the bottle with
some pebbles or sand put the cap back on
and place it in your tank so it reduces
the water used with each flush believe
it or not plumbing leaks account for
about fourteen percent of the water used
in the average home so it's a good idea
to check your toilet for leaks here's
how put 5 to 10 drops of food coloring
into the tank now put the lid back on
but don't flush wait about 15 minutes
and check the toilet bowl if you see any
food coloring there's a leak that's
wasting water well a steaming hot shower
can certainly be relaxing but it also
happens to be the second biggest
consumer of water in the bathroom shower
heads made before 1992 can draw up to
five and a half gallons of water per
minute so check to see if your
showerhead is old or new simply turn the
shower on full-blast catch all the water
in the bucket and wait exactly two
minutes if the bucket is overflowing
then the showerhead isn't a low-flow
model new showerhead started around $10
and installing one that draws two and a
half gallons or less
minute can save you 50% with every
shower now faucets also have flow rates
and if you take a look at the screw on
tip called the aerator that'll tell you
exactly what the flow rate of your
faucet is now if you suspect that your
faucets a water hog all you have to do
is unscrew the aerator and take it to a
hardware store and match it to a new
aerator that's the same size the most
efficient models have flow rates of no
higher than one gallon per minute now to
find the last water saving device in
your bathroom just look in the mirror to
save water all you have to do is learn
these few easy tricks and you're on your
way when you brush your teeth turn the
faucet off and use a glass of water to
rinse remember to put trash in the
wastebasket instead of flushing it away
skip the bubble bath and take a shower
instead taking a bath can use up to 7
times more water than a short shower
with a few simple changes right here in
the bathroom you can keep plenty of
water and money from going straight down
the drain thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time to find out how green
your bathroom is click on the link below
to take the quiz